OFF OF THE DEATH OF FOREIGN
AMERICANS.
ANYWAY.
THAT'S MY SPEECH.
>> Sean: HERE WITH REACTION
ALTHOUGH I'M SURE YOU DON'T WANT
TO WASTE MUCH TIME ON IT.
LINDSEY GRAHAM.
GREAT STATE OF SOUTH CAROLINA.
>> LAST TIME WE PLAYED GOLF.
IT WAS WORSE.
JUDGE ME BY MY ENEMIES.
I WILL TAKE THAT ALL DAY LONG.
>> Sean: I WANT TO GO BACK.
THIS IS AN INTERESTING POINT.
ADAM THE COWARDLY SCHIFF COME AS
A FACT WITNESS.
HIS TOP-SECRET VENEZUELA STYLE
OF IMPEACHMENT COUP ATTEMPT AND
REPUBLICANS CAN EVEN READ WHAT'S
GOING ON.
WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO CALL THEM
BEFORE YOUR COMMITTEE?
>> I DOUBT IT.
THE WHOLE INQUIRY HAS BEEN
REFERRED TO THE INTEL COMMITTEE.
I WILL GET AND PRETTY SOON.
HERE'S WHAT I'M GOING TO DO
TOMORROW AND I NEED YOUR HELP
QUITE FRANKLY.
I'VE GOT A RESOLUTION CONDEMNING
THE HOUSE PROCESS AS BEING
UN-AMERICAN, BASICALLY UNFAIR.
THE PRESIDENT CAN'T DEFEND
HIMSELF.
I'M TIRED OF THE PRESIDENT BEING
TRASHED BASED ON BEHIND THE
SCENES TESTIMONY.
THAT'S ONE-SIDED.
I'M ASKING THE HOUSE TO OPEN UP
AN INQUIRY CONSISTENT IN WHAT WE
DID WITH BILL CLINTON SO
PRESIDENT TRUMP DEFEND HIMSELF.
ADAM SCHIFF, IF HE DID COAST THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER, THAT WOULD BE
INTERESTING.
IF SOMEBODY DOESN'T FIND OUT WHO
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER IS HERE
PRETTY SOON, I WOULD BE A
MISCARRIAGE OF JUSTICE BECAUSE
THE WHOLE THING STARTED WITH AN
ANONYMOUS SOURCE.
>> Sean: SENATOR, LET ME GO
THROUGH THE LAST.
WE KNOW THAT NEWT GINGRICH
ALLOWED -- THIS WAS KEVIN
McCARTHY'S LETTER.
HE ALLOWED THE FULL HOUSE
AUTHORIZING THE IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY.
THEY ALLOW THE FULL HOUSE EVERY
CRITICAL STEP IN THE INQUIRY TO
INVOLVE THEMSELVES AND TO
DEVELOP A SCOPE.
ESTABLISH RULES AND PROCEDURES.
NEWT GINGRICH ALLOWED FOR THE
DEMOCRATS, THE COEQUAL RIGHT TO
SUBPOENA THE CHAIR AND THE
RANKING MEMBER.
BY THE WAY, ALL SUBPOENAS ARE
SUBJECT TO THE VOTE OF THE FULL
COMMITTEE AT THE REQUEST OF THE
CHAIR AND RANKING MEMBER.
BY THE WAY, THE PRESIDENT'S
COUNCIL ON THE RIGHT TO CONTENT
ALL HEARINGS, ALL THE POSITIONS.
HE HAD THE RIGHT TO PRESENT
EVIDENCE.
THE RIGHT TO CROSS-EXAMINE.
THE RIGHT TO OBJECT TO EVIDENCE
THAT WAS ADMITTED.
ALSO THE PRESIDENT'S COUNCIL OF
THE RIGHT TO RECOMMEND A WITNESS
LIST.
NEWT GINGRICH DID THAT FOR
BILL CLINTON.
EVERYONE OF THOSE THINGS.
NONE OF THEM HAPPENED FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
>> NONE OF IT.
AS A MATTER OF FACT WHAT'S
HAPPENED HERE IS THAT THEY ARE
INTERVIEWING THE WITNESSES
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS AND THEY
GIVE THE MEDIA PART OF THE
TESTIMONY, DETRIMENTAL TO THE
PRESIDENT.
LIKE BILL TAYLOR'S OPENING
STATEMENT, HOW DID JOHN
RADCLIFFE DO WHEN IT CAME TO
CROSS-EXAMINING BILL TAYLOR?
YOU'LL NEVER KNOW THAT.
THEY'RE TRYING TO DRIVE THE
PRESIDENT'S POLL NUMBERS DOWN,
IMPEACHMENT POLL NUMBERS UP BY
USING BASICALLY STAR CHAMBER
TACTICS.
THIS IS A POLITICAL MOVE BY
DEMOCRATS THAT WILL DESTROY THE
PRESIDENCY IN THE FUTURE.
IT'S A LEGITIMATE AND I WILL
CONDEMN IT AND I HOPE EVERY
REPUBLICAN WILL JOIN MY
RESOLUTION URGING THE HOUSE TO
DO FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP WHAT
NEWT GINGRICH DID FOR
PRESIDENT CLINTON.
GIVE HIM A CHANCE.
>> Sean: YOU SAID LAST NIGHT
AFTER GOING TO DO -- AND NOT
ALLOW DUE PROCESS, NOT ALLOW
WHAT REPUBLICANS ALLOWED
BILL CLINTON AND THE DEMOCRATS
DO HAVE GREAT NOT LONG AGO,
1998.
THERE WERE 11 FELONIES IF I
REMEMBER.
IF THE NECK WENT TO ALLOW THAT
TO HAPPEN, THAT WOULD BE -- THAT
WHOLE INQUIRY WOULD BE LACKING
IN ANY VALIDITY TO ME.
IT WOULD MEAN IT'S
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
IT WOULD ALSO MEAN THERE IS NO
DUE PROCESS AND I DON'T THINK
THAT'S ANY RESPECTABLE,
REPUBLICAN SENATOR SHOULD ALLOW
TO HAPPEN WITHOUT DISMISSING IT
OUT OF HAND.
>> WE ARE JUST NOT SURE A SPADE
WE COULD MAKE
MOTIONS TO DISMISS ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT.
HERE'S WHAT I PROMISE YOUR
AUDIENCE I WILL DO.
IF THEY CONTINUE TO TREAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP THIS WAY, TRYING
TO BEHIND CLOSED DOORS ENTERED I
HAVE THE ABILITY TO CONFRONT HIS
ACCUSER AND THEY -- THIS RESULTS
IN THE IMPEACHMENT ARTICLE.
I WILL MOVE TO DISMISS IT AND
THE SENATE BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
ILLEGITIMATE AND
NONCONSTITUTIONAL AND I WILL DO
IT NOT ONLY TO HELP
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO DESERVES TO
BE HELPED.
TO HELP FUTURE PRESIDENTS FROM
KANGAROO COURT PROCEEDINGS IN
THE HOUSE.
ALL I'M ASKING DEMOCRATS TO DO
WAS HAVE A TRANSPARENT PROCESS
LIKE WE DID WITH CLINTON AS OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN MAKE A
DECISION AS TO WHAT HAPPENED AND
NOT RELY UPON A BUDGET DEMOCRATS
TO TELL US WHAT HAPPENED.
>> Sean: CHANGING GEARS.
WERE WAITING, WERE WAITING.
THE REPORT ON THE FISA ABUSE.
JOHN SOLOMON IS SAYING, THE
EFFECTS HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED
THAT IT WAS AN UNVERIFIABLE
DOSSIER.
IF YOU ARE MEMO ALONG WITH
CHARLES BRADLEY SAID THE BULK OF
INFORMATION IN THAT APPLICATION
CAME FROM THE RECLAIM DAN'S
DIRTY DOSSIER.
NONE OF IT VERIFIED.
THE TOP OF THE FISA WARRANT.
THAT WOULD MEAN PREMEDITATED
FRAUD ON THE COURT.
IF I DID THAT, YOU'RE A GREAT
LAWYER, YOU COULDN'T GET ME OUT
OF JAIL WITHOUT SPENDING FIVE
YEARS AT LEAST.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF I COULD GET
YOU OUT OF JAIL IN THIS WORLD AT
ALL.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS, --
>> Sean: YOU MAY NOT WANT ME
OUT.
>> I DO WANT YOU OUT.
YOU NEED TO BE RIGHT WHERE
YOU'RE AT.
THE ONLY THING LEFT TO DO IS TO
MAKE SURE THERE IS NO CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION THAT WOULD HURT OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY AND NOTIFY
PEOPLE THAT ARE MENTIONED AT THE
AIRPORT TO GIVE THEIR INPUT.
WE'LL BE GETTING IT PRETTY SOON.
CAN I ADD ON THE SUSAN RICE
THEN?
THE BOTTOM LINE, EVERYTHING SHE
TOUCHED TURNED TO A PIECE OF.
NATIONAL SECURITY WISE.
IT BOTHERS ME THE PERSON WHO
LIED ABOUT BENGHAZI IS STILL
RELEVANT.
HERE'S HER GREATEST HEAD, IRAN
NUCLEAR DEAL, WITHDRAWAL FROM
IRAQ, WITHDRAW OF ISIS AT THE
END OF THE DAY THE RWANDA, THE
SYRIAN REDLINE.
THE BOTTOM LINE, I HOPE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL REMEMBER
THAT SUSAN RICE AND BARACK OBAMA
WHO BROUGHT YOU ISIS, WHO GAVE
THEM HUNDRED $50 BILLION.
AT THE END OF THE DAY IF SHE
DOESN'T LIKE ME, I MUST BE DOING
SOMETHING RIGHT.
>> Sean: AMEN.
I AGREE WITH THAT.
SHE DOESN'T LIKE ME EITHER, AT
LEAST I HOPE SO.
SENATOR, KEEP UP THE GOOD WORK.